Speaker 1: in his first podcast episode since
we learned that at least Donald Trump thinks
he's about to get arrested. Donald Trump Junior
delivered a manic episode seemingly about what is
happening with his dad. I've never seen Junior
like this, and I've seen Junior pretty hopped
up. He also seems to have developed like a new
accent for his podcast, where he speaks in an
extraordinarily strange way. And his show is
called Triggered, which is very, very apropos
of his demeanor here. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Who really gives a crap about law
when you're weaponizing your office
in a leftist state and where everyone
there agrees with you? Most of the
prosecutors there don't know what
the hell to do about this because even they
like the most radical of the radical left.
Speaker 1: Isn't this the most bizarre delivery?
Speaker 3: Realize that. It's insane. Hilarious.
Like, isn't she, like, paying his
legal bills or something like that?
I don't know. But, you know, the district
attorney is going to district attorney. Right.
The Soros Fund, the district attorneys
are going to do whatever the guy that's
bankrolling them wants them to do. The law
be damned, the Constitution be damned. Your
rights be down. Because you know, when you
hate America, what difference does it make?
This prosecution isn't based on facts or the
law or anything that even resembles that.
Speaker 1: How would he know that?
Speaker 3: Pure Bolshevik style?
Speaker 5: Which country?
Speaker 3: But the hot take on Twitter was
that these guys are trying to do this. This was
the hot, stupid take on Twitter over the weekend,
like the dumbest take ever that they're trying
to do this to make sure Trump's the nominee. Like
they weren't trying to put him in jail for the
last eight years. Like, they didn't accuse me and
the rest of my family of treason and other things.
Speaker 1: Okay. And then at another moment,
I guess ostensibly, JR on this episode was
interviewing Ronny Jackson, the Republican
congressman who used to be Trump's doctor. And
again, it's like it's not really an interview
because Junior is just ranting uncontrollably.
Speaker 5: You know, as you know, I had a really
good relationship with a lot of guys on my Secret
Service detail. So much so that it moved guys
off of my detail because they were like, Oh,
you're too comfortable with this. I was like,
I promise you guys, like, you want me comfortable
with my guys because if something goes wrong,
like I'm the guy that thinks I'm
always right, Like, I get that. Like,
I want to like the guy because I'll trust them.
Speaker 3: Everybody knows you had more guns in.
Speaker 5: The well that we won't even
get into that. They clearly, clearly. So,
you know, we had a good time. But, you know, the
one sort of thing and, you know, four years of,
you know, guys rotating in and out, I mean, that
was the one thing they said with you. You know,
you took care of that. Those guys, too, you know,
when they were going on international trips,
when they were pulling multiple day type.
Speaker 1: Understand that what Junior is
doing now is saying Ronny Jackson, as Trump's
doctor, would give sleeping medication to Secret
Service agents, that that's really the
core of what he is praising him for here.
Speaker 5: Writers, you were the guy that took
care of everything that they ever needed and did
so, so professionally. Those guys love you. Yeah.
Speaker 3: And you know, that.
Speaker 5: Stuff means so much more to me
than if the boss likes you, right? You know,
when the guys that.
Speaker 3: You know.
Speaker 5: You could blow off, right? You
know, I don't need to pay attention to the
lowly. Whatever. He's not high up on the totem
pole. He can't help my promotion or my career.
Right. You know, when those guys are a huge
fan, you know, that's when I'm like, okay,
yeah. Now, I respect that so much more.
Speaker 3: And so watching that attack.
Speaker 5: On you, read it again. A rear
admiral obviously served in the Navy.
Speaker 1: Just a bizarre, bizarre show
altogether. And maybe the most interesting
thing about the Don Junior Show on Rumble is
that it in the last 3 to 5 days has taken a
decidedly anti Ron DeSantis perspective. And
that's what I want to briefly look at next